comment il explique la centaine de cas
en israël deux personnes qui étaient
vaccinés et qui ont attrapé la maladie
quand on explique le vaccin n'est pas
efficace à 100 % d'accord général
et puis il ya les variants qu'ils n
redistribuer les cartes et les variantes
sont favorisées par les vaccins
tous les gens qui ont étudié le problème
à l'évasion immunitaire et fès est
favorisée par le vaccin
delfraissy il dit et ça avait été un
point pris fin janvier aussi il va
falloir vacciner 90% la population pour
éviter l'émergence de nouveaux variants
parce que quand on va se battre on sait
pas c'est pas vrai parce que les
variants arrivé avant donc vous allez
vacciner 90% de la population d'une part
le variance est déjà arrivé en israël
quoi qu'il arrive et je pense avoir il
ya des gens qui demandent aussi à ce que
les des jeunes de 18 à 30 ans vont
pouvoir être vacciné un jour il va
falloir les maxi et les convaincre de se
vacciner
surtout pas pourquoi est-ce qu'on
vaccinerait des gens qui n'ont pas de
risque de la maladie en dessous de 30
ans c'est pas vrai qu'il y ait des morts
sauf des gens à très très fortes comme
d'air guinée serait morte par ailleurs
mais on se concerte devrait comprendre
je passe sur le discours vous a vue sur
les personnes âgées plus faibles' labour
pas possible quel est l'intérêt pour
vous ce soir de venir ici sur ce plateau
et de raconter tout ça aux gens qui nous
regardent au monde entier qui est qui
s'est mobilisé depuis depuis des mois et
des mois pour crédits impayés mois des
vaccins peau c'est de faire en sorte que
ça émeut quel est l'intérêt dans votre
tête
moi j'aimerais comprendre ce qu'il fera
dans votre tête pour venir bien ici ce
bateau ne fait pas le vaccin tout ça
faisait rare et n'ai pas dit ça j'ai eu
un trou noir et voulait dit des filles
n'ont que des gens veulent se faire
vacciner c'est l'endroit le plus strict
et je ne le conteste surtout pas un
vous avez conscience des conséquences
que vous dites à la télévision française
mais je sais cela dit et je l'avais pas
simplement qu à vacciner les enfants si
leur faire courir un risque sans aucun
pays ne disparaîtront pas les enfants et
personnes en fait nous lâcher prise de
risque
à kumbag était effectivement c'est
logique encore faudrait-il que le vaccin
marche
or il est bien ce but d'accéder vous sur
terre ne ment pas voila voila tellement
pas certainement pas parce que j'ai pas
de co bordeaux green it et j'ai aucune
comme bob édité et donc je vois pas
pourquoi je je je
alors vous avez rien compris l'épidémie
a fait ça vous n'avez rien compris à
l'épidémie ne pourront aller vous qui
avez regarde son père
vous allez de mourir debout quand on a
mieux c'est l'âge de 75 ans parmi les
personnes qui risquent d'aller en
réanimation sixième année j'espère qu'on
voulait être après pas mais n'est-il pas
par gecas dire s'il existe des
traitements même si vous n'y a pas de
parents cela s'ils avaient à des
traitements efficaces vous pensez
réellement que c'est la chloroquine
ivermectine ou la peau ne parla pas
marché on en sera encore là là je peux
vous dire d'aurel et plusieurs de mes
amis qui ont eu des femmes vivent dehors
de mes amis hockey oui moi j'aime à
nantes au bled elle a eu une fois un peu
de curcuma j'ai eu plusieurs
effectivement des amis qui est attrapant
le covin lors de la première vague 1
nous ont appelés au secours en disant le
mon médecin refuse tout traitement
qu'est ce que je pourrais faire
on lui a donné ce qu'on pouvait lui
donner donc tout simplement qu est-ce qu
on donne quand une grippe est mauvaise
la grippe tue effectivement les vieux
qui sont fatigués qu'on beaucoup de coco
mobilisés à dax mais simon dunn c'est
pas vrai du tout il faut les traiter
il faut les arrêter non mais si les
antibiotiques ça permet d'éviter les
conditions générales des antibiotiques